R
THOSE
FIUTENT TREW WITHBOBWOOD HEREAS
REACTION. WHAT WAS PRESIDE X
SA
>> WE WERE TALKING MY T VIS.S GE
GOOD
YUATION.OUGH AIR, BOB.OUGHER TH
TOHT AIR, YOU JUST BREATHE
THAT'S HOW  A VERY ICKY THAT'S
WHO WOULD EVER THINK PRETTYAMAZ
THIS IS MOREDEADLY. S
TH1%, SO THIS IS DS USWE ON A T
THE WITH   GN PHONEITNG AND PIS
NOTHING TO WORRY ABOUT IT'S
GOTO LIKEMIRACLE.
TMP EX AND HE SAID TRD TAKE
ASTEN. T TO ALWAYSLAWN I LIKE BT
S ABOUT
>> YEAH, T WE HAVE
CONFIDENCE IN HISLEADERSHIP.
SAW WHAT COLUMDICAL SCHOOL POIN
MARCH. ACTED ONE WEEK
THERE WO IVE.
TWO WESEARLIE
ALIVE.
THIS CAUSED PPL DIE.
WHID HE D
ACKNOWLEDGEDOU ITIT'S IN THEAI.
HE ABOUT IT'S
RIDICULOON A WHATOC
WHY HAVE RULES?
IT WAS ALL ABOUT MAKING SURE TH'
LOSE ANY  THAT HE
COULD STHAT,FACT,HA  TO
AVEDDAW DO A DAMN THING.
IT.THINT HE DIDDOOST IMINAL.
>> WOODWARD REPORTS SECRETARYMEN
COLLEIV ACTION WITHDAN COS,IRE
INTELLIGENCE BECAUSE UNFIT.
COATS COULDN'THA THEN THASOMETHR
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS
ELECTRIC HIS ADVISERS.
ONEND HIM HRUPT HIS
THINKINGIN.D OATH -- I
SHLDTHAT, S TO THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC, H  ON HOW DROR,
HAVENYDO WITH
HE SAW THE
NEHEM I DEIL LEA CAN
WHY IN GOD'S NAMEIDN'T MOVE
QUICKER ON THPRODUCTI PTHE PROI
FIRST RESPONDERS.
WHY DIDN'T DO
OKAY.HE DOESN'T WANT PANIC
AT LEAST MAKEEE HAVE
THE EQUIPME ST UTION.TVE THAT.
>> H RELATIV THE
UN A OVER THESPECTRUM.
HOW DO YOU MAKE ANAVEXAS WHO
SAYEAH, THEIRUS IS
HORRMPCHINA'S LET'S  LET'S TAKE
TRUM
WHY DID HE SAY TRANSPARENT  AND
GOING TO Y DID HE INSIST THE44
NSISTING THEYO AND CCESS TO SEEW
DETAIL INSIS.RUS IS NOT HIS FAU
DERE HIS FAULT BECAUSE
HE COULD HOMT IT,  TO YOUR UNCLT
HE SAIDNOTHING.HE SAID THERE'S
WEARING MASK.
HE ACTUALLY ASSUGG ATIONEROMN T
LO W
AGAIN, 00 HE DOING NOW.
HE STILL HOTOK AT THE SCHOOLSOP
STARTING OFFCH LIKE T LAS HOME.
THINK OF ALLPLE THAT
DON'T HAVTHE RESOURCES TO DO
A SINGLE MOM I TO $7OURR H
WITH KID.
I CAN'T AFFORDANYBODY.
>> ONE OTHEREVELATION FROM THE
BOOK, TRUMP APPEARS
REVEALED A NEW CLASSIFIEDWEAPONF
IT TO WOODWARD. SAID,QUE, BM
NUCL WEAODHA RE, HE
EXTE OD
WEAPONS SY
WHAT'S YOURES TO AT CAN'T SPEAKR
YOLLIGENCE COMMITTEE WONDERED
FROM THE VERYINFY  HIM,
BETHEY DON'T WHAT HE WILL  NO CI
SOUND- HAS NOONIO OF
WHAT CONSTITUTES NATIONAL
NO OTHER THAN  HEOELF.
THIS I THE GUY W S
THE TO DEAL WITH HURRICASIS TO
IT. KNOW.
>> OR THE PROBLEM WH
REVOLUTIONARY WAR WAS HAVE ENOUR
I
COMPREHENSION. REALLYRS ME,T
REALLY BOTHERS ME, YOU WROTE A
WROTE A BOOK A AFGHANISTAN.
WANE OF THOSEOBs,PERATINGBASES.A
WA Y IMAGINE TO KEEPTHINGS FROM
HE CALLS THEM SUCKER TO GO AS
ASSISTANT U.S.
PHILADELPHIA TO OVO.
HE WAS THERE SIX NTHS.
ERECTED A T
KISERVIC
I THK ONLY AMERICAN THEY
DID   A ER?ER AY
GENERAL OF THE STATE DELTO GO UE
SUCKER -- I JUST HEROES.THEY REN
OR WHATEVER
HIS LIT TEST OTEST HEE DOESN'T
UNDERS  HONOR,UNTRY.
HEOE GETIT.
F H  HE DSNCARE ABOUT IT.
HE SHOULD NOT
MY RUNNING,ECO